[Musique]
la vie si toucan est astucieux peine
à ses yeux le plus sérieux et a joué il
n'y a jamais
[Musique]
tu vas là dans une sacrée format non je
me secoue mais je ne devrais pas
pourquoi la fête de la bile mais
qu'est-ce que je ne suis pas oui petit
tout petit tout mais oui tu n'as pas vu
bah j'ai profité
et toi piquant bull n'avait pas vu thi
thu alors je n'ai pas vu l école des
panthers
voilà pourquoi t'as dépenses on le doit
dater le jour de l'efym aujourd'hui des
fait mal et il est aujourd'hui tout
quand je mendie pas ce que j'ai pu j'ai
rien préparé
non mais moi j'ai préparé une expérience
étonnante as tu vas voir assez
formidable j'espère que je vais la
réussite
donc attention voici une bouteille pas
la bouteille est vide
ça vaut mieux vous faites une sorte de
petit collier comme cela avec un carton
très souple vous le mettez en équilibre
sur la bouteille puis vous prenez une
petite pièce de monnaie une pièce de 5
centimes fait très bien l affaire
la pièce vous essayez de la m très
exactement au dessus du boulot il faut
pas essayer fola mais bon c'est pas
toujours facile
tiens tu vois j'ai raté ma bien-aimée a
tant aidé quand c'est moi qui prépare un
voilà alors que tu fais maintenant il
faut que je me concentre ne te moque pas
de moi ça devrait aller
vous prenez un crayon un simple crayon
et alors là mes enfants il faut que ça
marche
faut se concentrer je passe le crayon à
l'intérieur de l'anneau et si je tire
d'un coup sec
en principe la pièce tombe exactement
dans la bouteille jeudi en principe
parce que t'es pas te marche pas
toujours attention aux liens et là ça
n'a pas marché alors attendez chercher
mon collier je reviens le collier et la
ribot la pièce ça va être plus délicat
parce que je travaillais là il y en a
dans l'établissement et plusieurs la
voilà bon genre commence
attention tu vois je t'avais dit que
s'arrêter de temps en temps on remarque
à dacia 6,6 trop facile en baisse et pas
assez pas musan si c'est trop facile
3 4 et voilà
for me formidable ça c'est très bien
c'est un bon jeu c'est un très bon jeu
ce site est aussi fort maintenant au
mot-à-mot on va faire ça on va voir on y
va pour le mot à mot ce retrait je
veille à l'hôpital rien ici où ils sont
pétris de regarder voilà voilà
hop tu expliques et bunge expliques tu
sais je crois que nos amis maintenant
ont bien compris comment marcher la
faire en réalité nous allons tirer des
cartons sur lesquels vous verrez des
dessins ses dessins représentent un
certain nombre de choses ou des animaux
et forme un mot bon l'asile à m sila
puis une syllabe et à partir de ses
syllabes nous nous essaierons de former
d'autres mots est comme un petit puzzle
je crois qu'il vaut mieux le faire c'est
encore plus simple que l'expliqué alors
j'en prend combien pour commencer la
dernière flèche je dois dire que c'est
ces pics en bout les toits qui nous
avions gagné nous allions gagner
souviens bien
alors j'en prends congrès eh ben tu en
prends tu as pensé aller au hasard 2 3 4
et 1 5 bord un ratio qui va les mettre
sur le table
oui je l'aimé je les mets absolument sur
le tableau à temps j'ai oublié mon
panier je viens le reprendre et la
sphère est fait car nous aurons
peut-être besoin tout à l'heure d'autres
cartons alors une si c'est bien ça oui
ça c'est un pan nous sommes d'accord oui
oui c'est exactement ça oui bah
j'aimerais bien que tu me le disent
alors ça c'est un verre une coupe c'est
un vrai revers ça c'est une selle selles
une selle et puis alors là nous avons
bien évidemment un phare non madame
qu'est ce qu'on va faire avec ces mots
là bas je sais pas moi il faut essayer
de former un un mot avec 6,1 à ce que je
vois pas grand chose m'arrive à moi j'ai
une idée
oui j'ai une idée oui c'est pas si on a
le droit mais je voudrais faire farsi
comme une tomate farcie bravo à la
tomate farcie regarde regarde phare un
phare et si la syrie bravo évidemment ça
ne s'écrit pas comme un phare et une si
elle va bien et ça s'est fait de cette
façon là car si tu me le demande pas
comment ça s'écrit à vaut mieux pas non
parce que tu n'es pas très fin en
orthographe
alors si c'est une tomate farcie nous
allons écrire c'est i e
parce qu'il s'agit d'une tomate 1 mais
uniquement dans ce cas là sinon cfa rci
lait farci pour une femme anna c'est
bien joué 1
c'est bien c'est bien pour ça il faudra
vous on peut rien faire avec les pires
nom soit retiré d'autres combien j'en
tire tire un sixième
oui oui d'après toi c'est quoi ça sert
oui oui un d eux aussi un rôle important
ben euh c'est le nom s'investir encore
eu l'an passé encore une encore une fois
tiré un autre encore une sas et un coq
commis en continu continu montant global
orr
ah voilà le mal las palmas du bateau
robolis oui j'ai une question à te poses
with rich compris le pouce moussu avait
facilité par si oui mais avec l'eau m'a
et je pourrais améliorer et faire la
pharmacie eux à pied droit oui ça ça me
paraît très astucieux oui alors comment
b6 et répond ça regarde on met le mât
entre phare et si et ça fait phare m'a
même volé mais le mot de pouce musique
elle ne bougera pas vrai je veux pas
qu'ils veulent mon bon ami lac droit il
a le droit il a le droit comme membre il
a le droit à bon alors là encore ça
remet à 6 écrit différemment phares
comme cela fars ma et si c est une
pharmacie
c'est bien joué ça tu sais à ravir c'est
très astucieux les rapidos alors qui va
pouvoir tirer leur sert à l'aise pour
gagner c'est rapidos qu'à gagner et
rapido sois gentil de me désigner une
lettre d'un petit ami tu as mulhouse
c'est là la seule c'est là que je tiens
à mouiller
d'accord il s'agit d'une lettre qui nous
vient de la taille faut que j'ouvre ce
là où il ya même un beau dessin ont
plusieurs choses à l'intérieur
et oui je vais vous montrer le dessin
vous voyez les rats 10 ans ont là un
très très joli dessin bien petit mot
pour les quatre amies et je m'appelle
sylvie momères bonsoir sylvie elle
habite bourg en bresse et elle voudrait
aussi un disque de la chanson des quatre
amis je crois qu'il n'y a pas de
problème et rapido se fera un plaisir de
te l'envoyer très rapidement ce jeu-là
paultre mois
oui alors là ça n'arrivera peut-être pas
très vite pas qu'hambourg si c'est toi
même qu'il apporte enfin nous verrons
cela à sylvie c'est promis tu auras
bravo bravo alors dit dont fabrice à ça
va être à nous maintenant oui push mais
alors c'est le mot comme d'habitude
d'habitude tu as ton tweet at-on
marqueur et quand je ne pas faire de
fautes d'orthographe
mais c'est d'une vessie ebay alors andy
lettre un mot en dix lettres cette
semaine première lettre
oui la première lettre c'est un b oui
voilà
et alors les u12 miroir 4 5 6 cette
limite est la dernière l'est alors la
dernière 1 1
hum hum voilà alors naturellement ce
n'est pas une plante
ce n'est pas un animal non comme
d'habitude qu'on jouait avec des moyens
de locomotion de transport est
exactement moyen de transport alors
est-ce que souvient de transport
utilisent les rails
non non non non on utilise palayret la
route de la route rui défaut la route la
route oui ça peut être un chemin aussi
un chemin aussi un chemin
oui demain une autre lettre tu veux tu
la quatrième lettre la quatrième la
quatrième c1 i la 4e puis 1 2 3 4 1 à 1
y voit là un lit alors eu un oui
c'est abc il ya un moteur sur son man ou
non il n'y a pas de maintenant il n'y a
pas de moteur le panier ya pas de moteur
ça se dépasse quand même et ça se
déplaçant assez vite assez vite oui faut
avoir de la force
ah bon c'est lancé c'est l'amour qui
fait qui fait marcher la machine qui
fait marcher la machine marcher la
machine
non c'est pas possible ne me dis que
c'est possible de le faire marcher ne me
dit pas ne me dis pas que tu as pensé à
ce à quoi je pense brusquement oui
bicyclette la bicyclette apaiser des
sites l'athlète et oui ça s'écrit
commandes et s'est créé pas cessé ghrib
et y cic l e de théo bicyclette
massatois à je suis chopé un titre à
gaza alors qu'israël est bicyclette
puis elle apprendre ça s'écrit comme ça
b oui i
ce qui veut dire deux à bord puis 2 2
oui et cycle est il faut y abondent
incapable aricie clair oui
te voilà comment on écrit bicyclette ou
tu es toujours aussi nul que je savais
qu'il y avait un y terry cap as fait
pour être voilà le profil est mal placée
gemalto est ce que tu sais ce que tu
sais que quand on a inventé la
bicyclette est us est elle plus
difficile à trouver un
eh ben je vais te le dire les freins
puis on arrivait on n'arrivait pas à
trouver les freins le freinage il arrive
à la faire marcher mais n'arrive pas à
freiner et oui c'est drôle les
inventions vie moitié si on allait
retrouver bell bell fabrice vial jury
avec moi c'est pas si la musique
tibétains oui ma chanteuse vient écouter
attentivement nous allons jouer à notre
petit jeu musical je suis prêt tu
connais le principe du jeu j'étais
raconte une histoire courte au cours de
laquelle je laisse certainement inachevé
une fois tu complète ses mots à l'aide
de notes de musique que tu placera sur
cette portée et quand j'aurai fini tu
t'apercevras que toutes ces notes se
donne l'air de la chanson dont je vais
précisément de raconter l'histoire
bon alors c'est une histoire qui se
passe la nuit quand de la ville tout le
monde est endormi et que brusquement on
entend un bruit épouvantable
on dirait qu'il ya là toute l'équipe de
co ro comme une équipe de télé à la wic
oh là là on voit là alors bien sûr les
gens se réveillant en sursaut
on entendait
qu'est-ce que si tu vas tu vas là voilà
tu m'as parlé alors tous ces braves gens
se précipitent à leurs fenêtres en
bonnet de coton et en show the je me
dise ce mise
il ne fait pas très chaud beaucoup sont
sombres souffler dans leurs couverts
m'étouffe le lait oui ils ne sont pas
contents du tout ces braves gens ils ont
été payants cherche au ray réveiller a
dit d'anticiper un petit malin il faut
avouer que pour ces gens ce n'est pas
très drôle mais que pour ceux qui sont
en bas dans la rue c'est un spectacle
clasico que comique comics aux boules
j'aime bien quand tu viens me dérange et
de regards le regard du jeune je ne vous
dérange pas de regard rivé tout de même
des anges
bon alors qu'est ce que je te disais oui
mais là il ya du monde à toutes les
fenêtres ou alors sur une voie personne
c'est que les gens sont restés cachés
derrière leurs groupes leur riz donc mon
dieu mon dieu mon dieu c'est pas facile
ce que je fais la morale alors la suite
tu la connaîtra dans la chanson dont tu
vas me lire les premières notes
alors là la mimi ré mi do ce qui
s'échappe
qu'est ce qui se passe ici
bayonne on a mangé
oui c'est quelque chose comme ça j'ai lu
le script rien vous n'avez pas vu la
paire non c'est ou non me vient là mon
petit tout il ne va pas tarder à arriver
fabrice arrive bien vite ce qui limite
la casse
déjà papa famille de quatre ans qui se
croient que la vie s'est désisté et
rzeszow fait des choses mais comme je ne
nie pas de mine war il frappe et
attention les quatre amis sont pas
reconnaissants rudy p 4 ça me semble
heureux carisaie mamés
oui
allons les gagner
à jouer aujourd'hui dit vouloir devenir
un ami
e
[Musique]